[Music]
in the more you know news for morning by
Simpsons did it first here are nineteen
of the most bizarre world records you
never knew existed nineteen biggest
booger
yo that's Pony like massive biggest
donut I actually want to know what the
love this [ __ ] when I was a kid I love
reading that Guinness World Records and
then the longest nails was this Indian
lady the longest hair was an Indian lady
it's in a bagel or something you know
why that was so interesting though it's
because he was either that or you could
read the Harriet Tubman book or whatever
ya cyclopædia right exactly but you know
well we're not gonna even tell them the
first one because a lot of these people
here they don't even subscribe to us oh
yeah so you gotta subscribe to just
kidding news to figure out what are
these top ten what is that world
breakers nineteen I'm just gonna leave a
message since Griffin no comeback Steve
you better subscribe right now
subscribing when we were just three
people that did subscribe not now they
did okay thanks thanks for subscribing
now we have Steve here yeah men awesome
so the first one is the farthest arrow
shot using feet which was forty feet
before in forty feet or one pairs of you
I don't know what the feeder we're
talking about don't look at that's don't
you have to do it with your feet no I
mean she's in that [ __ ] outfit and
everything that's archers out there
photos for the book I can't even get in
that position I usually see ladies and
bikinis doing that like been the magic
shows and [ __ ] oh well the circus or
whatever usually I'll be all tired I
can't say it Lee no target that's like a
double so the next one is most tattooed
man ever over 1,000 hours of body
modification what is that he's gonna
streak me doing blackface Oh Lewis
whole thing is covered I don't even know
what this ethnicity is his ethnicity is
sub-zero combat what the [ __ ] oh boy you
know he's definitely white dude come on
only white people do this he's trying to
be avatar it's a hero's okay don't
Samoan dudes get pretty tatted yeah he'd
be way bigger actually Australians some
Polynesians get on their face and stuff
too he's trying to be a part of the Blue
Man Group you know hopefully he's made
it he looks like a better genie then
[ __ ] it will smell also that that's not
sin but sin that was never genie I know
I said it all right
most toothpicks in a beard oh why are
people wasting their [ __ ] time what's
the number okay this guy's not athletic
you got to give him something what do
you think who's fixing up beard he
doesn't have any other Talent 500 but he
made it on JK news because he did this
oh holy [ __ ] a porcupine thousand it is
bid five hundred twenty thousand well
now that I saw the picture okay two
thousand five thousand I'm gonna say
four thousand twenty thousand I said
that all you did yeah so it's 3,500 I
was a closest [ __ ] look at that you
want absolutely necessary I said four
thousand oh you didn't even stop that I
know it must be at a bar it just little
drama yeah with the British say like how
would you think we did that with
clothespin it took him three hours and
13 minutes to put all that in his beer
that's a good beard it held it I want to
seem to shake it out if he sneezes and
what did they put in the counting so
three hours there's someone there with a
clicker sure that could be official yeah
one of my guilty pleasure is watching
dominoes fall I love it it's so soothing
right so what they do the really
sophisticated yeah I like it when they
make sounds much but I love the sound of
that
me too I like it when it goes into
things like yeah like it goes into a
clock or like a yeah and it goes up and
yeah one of those calls go was it go
group it traps trap Alma home alone [ __ ]
mousetrap shoes yes I'm like mousetrap
it's called something but I can't that
was name of the game board next one is
most tricks performed in bed by a man
dog homeless poker magician potato in
one minute what are you talking about
most tricks performed by a pig in one
minute
can you guess 17 - what
so the pig is just doing like dog true
17 to 1 they're smart as [ __ ] 81 a
minute - hey 62 a second 5217 it was 13
through 13 tricks if I was just pigs dad
I'd be ashamed 13 tricks in a minute
you're gonna become breakfast little
piggy and that's why we eat them hi it's
a jump on a pogo stick and how long just
anywhere oh hi Strunk jump oh my god Wow
Wow would never get the guy under there
I feel bad for him that's not the really
I was thinking like two feet but now
that I see that that's like the
magician's assistant everyone guess I
want it I want to win
yeah good 18 feet 1812 what else ten
feet so they have to land maybe they do
10 feet 20 it was 11.15 feet so 10 feet
wins going over I said 12 but you're
closer [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] everybody
I want the paired one well we're why
never one of the big ones one one one
you guys are losing next one longest
hair on a teenager so specific yeah man
come on longest war five feet wow that
is long that's feet ten feet okay five
feet ten feet she's Indian NC 8 feet
Monty you Pro oh no bro it's on now man
Huck what are you guess is well see 10 I
said 10
I'm gonna say his [ __ ] is 5 5 and
that's 8 feet of hair I think it's gonna
be nice today
it was 5 feet 7 inches I win oh Hawk
you're the only loser right now yeah
Hawking of you won what a [ __ ] is one
you can't guess all these loser records
you want to know the next of course
shortest living horse mail how tall is a
short is do we got a picture short is
living horse Oh 28 inches for it for you
3 48 inches I was gonna say 30
what was the with the stance 25 inches
32 inches then 25 she's really talking
but she's really I'm 32 25 20 2.36 thank
you what was her number then I won Oh 25
use my friend to I've known him longer
well he's right but I know I'm deeper I
think deeper I'm we have a male bond we
need you can never understand I've made
him cry ok I'm the winner must be nice
against closest I'm the winner must be
competition I need to keep going boy
someone to beat Joe ok largest hula hoop
spun by a female how many inches in
female spy really have any feeling
inches in Dana diameter the largest who
are they 24 25 who's it 23 16 23 16 give
me 18 feet damn just remember everybody
okay 25 that's gonna be the closest to
everything it was 17 18 and point 25
inches 18 oh yeah what's yours I said 16
ok this culture is this closer cuz it's
a 18 that's some [ __ ] you want to
and - I think so yeah you got to now yep
taking part I take back my middle finger
yourself maybe we're just judging like
they compete something I hope people
know that we were a hundred percent
serious right now I know ya [ __ ] hate
using okay smallest ball in inches
how about would guess worse and then
look at a picture obviously it's okay
that's a ball that's pretty cute in
height Tom yeah oh my god that the gun I
put a toothpick in his bid to high 22
inches 22 anyone else 40 inches 28 28
inches 28 you 23 24 24 28
it's one C 22 26.69 who is that you
right yes what was it yes what'd you say
he said 24 28 28
look closer okay another one larges that
guitar amplifier larges I'm just gonna
skip that one too many last one let me
just show you the photo Oh No so what
all we're trying to guess the height
under that one doesn't do justice with
picture I want to hear that [ __ ]
that's true 200 decibels most drum beats
in one minute
using a drumstick prosthetic what's a
drum like how many of you it's fire like
each hit oh you know in one minute one
minute with a prosthetic arm Oh 1,000
with one arm or two arms know what
there's no that's a machine this
two-on-two though is it boring like this
or just look two of them is it automatic
what does a 1000
in how long one minute how give me your
numbers people about 1000 you should
have waited for this guy he's a drummer
you go here's a no counting it easy too
you have no idea 210 210 210 210 see you
said a thousand Oh a thousand and one
I'm with the two hundred for your price
is writing me 240 is that it yeah number
is 2400 2040 can I just say you just
drafted all over me who drafted me
unbelievable such a good [ __ ] hate it
next video I'm out of here
I want the next video Gio just got 3
yeah I just wanted to beat him but he
said a thousand I said a thousand in one
and then she [ __ ] fussing horseshit
[Music]